[Musique]
vous trouvez que les mesures choisies
par le gouvernement pour nous faire
rester à la maison sont contraignantes
payer une contravention de 135 euros en
cas de dérogation au confinement est
pour vous un abus et bien estimez vous
heureux de ne pas habiter en indonésie
parce que là bas le gouvernement ne joue
pas dans la même cour edouard philippe
en effet face à la macif désobéissance
civile à laquelle doit faire face le
gouvernement indonésien de la part des
citoyens l'état a décidé de sévir
c'est plus précisément cousine d'arrout
uyuni succo attila chef du département
de sera gun sur l'île de java qui a eu
l'idée pour le moins farfelue de faire
peur aux habitants elle a décidé que
chaque personne qui serait arrêté dans
la rue sans raison valable serait
enfermé dans une maison hantée oui vous
avez bien entendu la responsable précise
l'idée est que s'il ya une maison vide
ont une maison hantée dans un village il
faut les cantonner les contrevenants si
l'idée peut paraître totalement
improbable ici en france il faut noter
qu'en indonésie les croyances au tour
des esprits sont encore très ancré dans
la culture populaire et ces menaces ont
été mises à exécution ainsi de nombreux
fonctionnaires de livres ont été
réquisitionnés pour identifier les
maisons hantées et y enfermer les gens
pour 15 jours comme quoi à chaque pays
sa méthode
et ouais oui gilles verdez c'est fou ça
alors il faut savoir que en indonésie a
un gros problème pour faire respecter le
confinement mais ça pour eux c'est un
châtiment mais tu es libre parce qu'ils
ont une crainte absolue des êtres
surnaturels
ça fait des alizés d'une tradition il
ils ont peur vraiment que des fantômes
arrive et pour eux c'est perry blocs là
c'est vraiment le châtiment extrêmement
dur au niveau des rings oui
effectivement ils ont ils ont très très
peur des esprits en famille et donc là
vraiment ça sera s'est classé comme un
châtiment divin
donc c'est quelque chose qui est presque
supérieur à la justice des hommes et nos
glaces vraiment c'est peut-être une des
façons de de les faire accepter de
confinement mais oui oui je sais valérie
versé au dessus 4e position du top 5 des
insolites en france il y en a qui ne
connaissent pas la crise du courant d'un
virus ce sont les cahmbers ce que vous
savez ce que c'est elles sont beaucoup
plus sollicités qu'avant et on veut leur
activité bondir depuis le début du
confinement
on va vous expliquer ce qu'est une call
girl jean michel maire vous savez ce que
c'est je le maîtrise sur le jeu ou
toulouse ira près merci jean michel mr
et bien au moins aujourd'hui on aura
trouvé un sujet de prédilection à
jean-michel en pleine période de
confinement facetime zoom skype et
d'autres applications de vidéo
conférences sont très utiles pour
travailler au pour prendre des nouvelles
de sa grand mère mais avec la solitude
que génère ce confinement il n'y a pas
que les grands mères qui sont sollicités
en vidéo en effet depuis le 15 mars
dernier un service en ligne est
particulièrement populaire chez les
hommes il s'agit des call girls
bref ces jeunes femmes qui pratiquent le
sexe par webcam avec des internautes
contre de l'argent des clients qui
depuis quelques semaines sont de plus en
plus nombreux à avoir recours à ses
services comme en a témoigné à bfm ava
moore call girl depuis cinq ans en
quelques semaines
mon activité a bondi de 50% désormais je
travaille au moins de 9 heures à 23
heures alors qu'en temps normal je garde
mes soirées pour lire un bond de son
activité qui permet à la jeune femme de
se faire de nouveaux clients et pas
seulement des célibataires j'ai mes
habitués mais aussi beaucoup de nouveaux
même les hommes mariés ou en couple
n'ont pas déserté ils s'enferment dans
leur salle de bain ou aux toilettes pour
me retrouver sur snapshot au sky une
activi
en plein boom mais attention si vous
avez l'intention de vous lancer tout
n'est pas si simple comme l'expliquent
n'y vit une autre professionnelle
au début cela peut coûter cher il faut
que je rentre dans mes frais j'ai du
matériel pour le son et la vidéo qui me
permettent de faire des prestations à hd
sans compter les accessoires ça doit
être rentable pour moi sans être trop
cher pour le client une sorte de youtube
heures sans slip comme quoi pour
certains corps de métier le confinement
a du bon oui voilà on a eu le témoignage
de knie vctv tayeb
[Rires]
alors oui ou non on ne veut pas casser
l'ambiance mais ça reste de la
constitution et il faut dire qu'il ya
beaucoup d'étudiantes et notamment aux
mineurs qui la font et c'est un vrai
sujet et le sujet de la prostitution
pendant le confinement c'est aussi un
vrai problème parce que effectivement
ces femmes qui sont obligés de vendre
leur corps pour gagner de l'argent sur
la non mais excusez moi c'est pas drôle
ce que je dis mais vraiment si grave
c'est bien de le dire jean michel à
laurent blanc je suis désolé de te
contredire mais un c'est pas considéré
comme de la prostitution il n'y a pas de
relation sexuelle entre ceux qui
regardent une image et ceux qui la
produisent
non mais la revanche des riches envers
les questions de morale je suis pas
d'accord quand même chose évidemment je
serais pas content voilà mais voilà et
la plupart du temps ces défis je connais
un peu le sujet sûr je connais des
filles qu'il le faut voilà donc ce lycée
est la plupart du temps elles ne sont
pas contraintes elles le font c'est
souvent d'ailleurs des anciennes
actrices x que le fort est que ça moyen
reconversion voilà et c'est souvent
qu'il n'ya pas de proxénètes derrière
marc effet c'est pas c'est pas un truc à
l'ancienne c'est quelle belle fille se
vante souvent sous le avec l'accord de
leur mari parce que ses rangs comme un
truc d'appoint ne dis pas que c'est
respectable
j'y vois là il ya des femmes qui font ça
comme ça c'est dans l'air du temps
je ne sais pas de jugement de valeur
mais c'est pas de la constitution du pot
merci jean michel qui avait de benoît de
remettre les choses à leur place en
numéro 3 des insolites tout comme roméo
juliette deux voisins confinés sur leur
balcon à vérone sont tombé éperdument
amoureux ça c'est une histoire assez
exceptionnel qu'on a trouvé les nouveaux
roméo et juliette regarde valérie ça va
te rappeler toi et patoche oui
ils s'aiment c'est de la 1ee mais c'est
ce qu'il ya de plus beau ok mais c'est
monter plus haut fais gaffe de ne pas
trop monter après tu as pu le voir
regarder
une chose est sûre le confinement n'est
pas le moment idéal pour faire des
rencontres
pourtant certaines personnes ne manquent
pas d'imagination pour continuer même
dans cette période compliquée à séduire
la belle histoire se déroule à vérone
dans le nord de l'italie une région
particulièrement touchée par l'épidémie
est à l'arrêt depuis de longues semaines
vérone qui est la ville dans laquelle
shakespeare a situé sa célèbre pièce
roméo et juliette
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que l'histoire de cette rencontre lui
ressemble par bien des aspects en effet
ces habitants qui sont voisins se sont
rencontrés en passant du temps à ceux
observés depuis chez eux
elle a son balcon lui à sa fenêtre les
deux inconnus qui habitent dans des
immeubles qui se font face ont tout de
suite le coup de foudre l'un pour
l'autre
très vite il décide de s'échanger leurs
instagram puis leur numéro de téléphone
aujourd'hui c'est le coup de foudre au
total une belle histoire qui tout comme
dans roméo et juliette est un amour
impossible car le coronavirus les
empêche de se rencontrer et de se
toucher
chaque jour ils se rencontrent derrière
un portail et échangent quelques mots un
masque sur le visage
une belle histoire qui sent le covin
n'aurait certainement pas été possible
selon michel s'il n'y avait pas eu
d'épidémie de coronavirus nous nous
serions probablement rencontré dans un
bar et je n'aurais pas eu le courage de
lui dire bonjour et elle ne m'aurait pas
remarqué une épidémie qui leur aura
permis de se sentir les rois du monde
j'ai eu droit devant
mais l'os au clic ghost à chaque fois
qu'on chante elle nous personne est qu
elle veut rentrer dans la danse jeune
fille est insupportable ou sentais
tellement bien c'est ouais c'est ça
assène on continue à mettre leur gueule
tu verras ouais ouais j'ai un don aussi
pour toujours avoir
j'ai un don pour des comptines et les
gens enlevés se fit sur wii c'est
l'absolue romantisme mais qu'est ce que
c'est beau c'est même par un regard sans
toucher pendant des semaines mais vous
vous rendez compte comment la passion va
brûler en eux ça va être extraordinaire
et wii party vont se rencontrer
je vais vous dire ça va être un volcan
d'auvergne
laurence williams qui s'exporte et la
mauvaise surprise parce que de loin
c'est toujours bien n'est pas halal
halal a raison c'est vrai que parfois de
loin on est beau et après on y voit un
beau de loin on ce désir de près on a
envie de partir vite chez soi oui je
sais simplement n'importe quoi moi pour
m attaché au radiateur bon je traverse
pas la rue pour voir même en cas sinon
c'est quoi ce truc contracture au petit
film d'hana on traverse la rue c'est
quoi on attend la fin de tout genre et
vous vous ne respectez rien les autres
lots et où jean michel maire mais on va
passer au numéro 2 des insolites et
alors justement ça parle de mariage
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de couples qui
ont dû annuler leur mariage à cause du
coronavirus mais pour celles et ceux qui
veulent vraiment se marier
sachez que ce sera peut-être bientôt
possible car en californie les mariages
ont repris dans des conditions très
particulières regarde alors que dans le
monde entier des milliers de couples
confiné depuis des semaines sont en
train d'organiser le futur divorce
tellement ils ne peuvent plus se
supporter en californie c'est tout
l'inversé certains ne peuvent même pas
attendre la fin du confinement pour se
marier et ça tombe bien puisque même
pendant le coronavirus c'est possible
c'est à peine croyable mais après
quelques semaines d'interruption totale
la responsable du comté d'orange à
quelques encablures de los angeles a
décidé d'autoriser à nouveau les couples
à s'unir mais attention ne vous attendez
pas au château de princesse à la
cérémonie en grande pompe et au
champagne qui coule à flots pour
respecter les gestes barrière du coc
vite 10
9 les candidats au mariage sont
regroupés sur le parking de la ville
d'anaheim avec un masque le responsable
de la mairie et quand elle lui protégé
dans une guérite derrière une vitre
épaisse
on va pas se mentir ce mariage sur un
parking et un peu moins romantique coup
de foudre à notting hill
espérons que pour leur lune de miel ces
couples mettre la barre un peu plus haut
[Musique]
ouais c'est pas moi y valérie ma chérie
non mais c'est trop c'est trop triste je
trouve ça un peu triste mais peu importe
que les moyens des uns et des autres
n'est pas obligé de faire un mariage
dans un château qui des millions mais ne
serait ce qu'un petit mariage intime
entre amis mais ma mairie avec joliment
décorées parking franchement non je
préfère et moi décalé attendre et faire
un truc marty même à dix personnes
mes infos julien / concluant valérie je
comprends jean michel mr ouai on dit
qu'ils sont séparés de l'officiant paris
je n'ai peut-être pas à vous je
n'apprendrai connaissez tous est ce qu
est ce que vous savez d'où vient notre
chèque comme ça qu'on achète la main
comme ça pas du tout mon genre me dites
le moi car là est bien c'est qu'on était
en prison et caen sont nombreuses que
les soirs les descendants parloir
albitre et ont posé là vite sur la main
sur la bible autre côté la main de
l'autre côté comme ça c'était un geste
de tendresse et d'amour comme ça et ma
pensée
bravo bravo en première position de
l'info insolite du jour
si le résultat d'une étude qui révèle si
oui ou non les français ont pris du
poids pendant le confinement
ça y est un à la réponse je vous le dis
je vous le dit ça y est et je peux vous
le dire
sachez que les français ont grossi de 86
g envoyée on attend que ça qui va
puisque les espagnols ont grossi de 117
grammes
les anglais 160 les allemands 189 les
italiens 195 g et les chinois 250
grammes c'est les chinois qui ont le
plus gros si vous voyez ça va 86 g
franchement on s'en sort très bien qu'on
parle aussi d'une info après laffaire de
villeneuve la garenne que beaucoup
considèrent voilà comme la paire aussi
du moment mais qui a été appelé au calme
bien entendu
je vous le dis il ya une autre affaire
qui est sorti aucun blessé rien de grave
d'après les images on voit un jeune
homme qui refuseraient de baisserait de
bci nice intégralement la vitre de sa
voiture à des policiers non masqué lors
d'un contrôle sur la vidéo en question
on voit que le jeune donne son
attestation et sa carte d'identité aux
policiers en en trouvant la vitre mais
ça n'a pas plu du tout aux forces de
l'ordre qui ont fini par arriver
conducteur voilà et son passager qui
filme et regardez où vous avez un petit
récap c'était aussi ça dans les
insolites puisqu'il voulait pas ouvrir
complètement sa vie tu regardes c'est
une vidéo qui ces dernières heures fait
le buzz sur snapshot et qui a été
relayée sur twitter une séquence dans
laquelle on peut assister à un contrôle
de police face à des policiers sans
masque qui se serait déroulée il ya
quelques jours des policiers qui malgré
le manque d'équipements aurait insisté
pour que le jeune homme sorte de son
véhicule et ou pro sa fenêtre un ordre
auquel il aurait refusé dans un premier
temps catégoriquement de se soumettre
face à l'insistance des policiers et
plusieurs minutes de négociations le
jeune homme accepte finalement de sortir
de sa voiture avant d'être plaqué
violemment contre la carrosserie une
scène entièrement filmée par le passager
du véhicule
une vidéo qui est un fake plusieurs
internautes ont identifié les policiers
commettant des comédiens dont certains
auraient déjà joué dans un clip du
rappeur djallit taux plus tard le jeune
homme a posté une vidéo clarifiant la
situation et précisant qu'il s'agissait
bien d'un sketch de 0,30 tournage de
milou une séquence qui aura beaucoup
fait parler ses dernières heures
voilà donc c'était voilà ce qu'un fake
bien entendu je voulais vous montrer ça
et c'est vrai que ça aussi ça fait le
buzz aujourd'hui